tonight's the opening game of the World
Series yeah opening game
opening game of the World Series here in
Los Angeles and it's a hundred and four
degrees outside
yeah so think of this while none of us
here are at the World Series at least we
have air conditioning okay why would you
want to be I feel sorry for people that
have those saw that thing this is gonna
be more historic yeah sure
hey you didn't know this the average
ticket for tonight's Dodgers Astros
World Series game is about $3,000 $3,000
for one ticket yeah I'm not crazy
for that kind of money you could see
half of Hamilton because that plays
expensive all right no is it I love
explaining them certain continues to be
problems that President Trump wherever
he goes there's arguments there's fight
yeah that's thing that's this thing
Priam he's claimed that is his thing
President Trump and Republican senator
bob Corker are in a feud after corker
compared the White House to a daycare
center yeah yeah when they heard this
three-year-olds everywhere I said oh no
do not lump us in with that guy
hi
that's my three-year-old character I see
yes a lollipop right planing it again
Bill O'Reilly revealed Bill O'Reilly has
his problems Bill O'Reilly revealed that
he is mad at God for putting him through
his sexual harassment scandal yeah
today God refused to comment and instead
she just laughed God's a woman uh I
gotta I'm gonna explain every single one
in that even though they're doing fine I
just like explaining them gives me more
to do yeah
a California elementary school was under
fire for putting up a Donald Trump
scarecrow yeah
even worse thirty percent of the crows
still think the Trump scarecrow is doing
a great job that's how many people
support him I want to be the only guy in
late-night that does this yeah it's like
this is gonna be my thing instead of ESL
it's like comedy for a second lang
exactly yeah people understand so you'll
get used to it I'm gonna do this every
night you're gonna love it
hey check this out I'll never do that
again don't worry you'll never see that
again
yeah
well you'll woo anything now foreign
policy experts say that the president of
China is now the world's most powerful
person yeah as you can imagine that came
as quite a shock to Beyonce so that one
cuz she's a huge star massive star Wow
hey get this when asked if he was
running for Senate in 2018
Kid Rock said and this is a quote no
yeah ladies and gentlemen that kind of
language can only mean one thing he's
running for president because that's the
level of our discourse anywho I'm out
here for myself tonight Nickelodeon
you've heard this Nickelodeon has fired
a mail producer after multiple
accusations of sexual harassment yeah
that's right he's the creator of
Nickelodeon's spongebob No Pants
[Applause]
you